.
>> Shannon: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I'M IN FOR BRET BAIER.
THE SUMMIT BETWEEN PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME HE IS
PRESIDENT AND SENDING SIGNALS
ABOUT A TOUGH APPROACH ABOUT A
NUMBER OF ISSUES.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY STARTS US OFF FROM
SWITZERLAND.
GOOD EVENING PETER.
>> Peter: SHANNON, GOOD EVENING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ALREADY HERE
IN GENEVA, PRESIDENT PUTIN
ARRIVES IN THE MORNING.
THE PLAN IS NOT FOR THE TWO
LEADER NOT TO SHARE A MEAL AT
ANY POINT BUT THERE IS A TIME
BUILT IN FOR BREAKS AND MEETING
IS EXPECTED TO LAST FOUR OR FIVE
HOURS.
WITH THAT BIDEN LEAVES A
FRIENDLY MEETING WHERE THE EU
APPEARED US SETTLED A LONG
STANDING ARE DISPUTE BETWEEN
ARABS AND BOEING AND HEADS TO
SWITZERLAND FOR A SIT DOWN WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> I THINK PUTIN HAS BEEN
TESTING THIS PRESIDENT
PARTICULARLY WITH THE
CYBERATTACKS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
RECENTLY.
>> Peter: A SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL OUTLINED
THREE OF THE TOPICS FOR THE SIT
DOWN.
RANSOMWARE ATTACKS LIKE THOSE
LAUNCHED FROM INSIDE RUSSIA THAT
SQUEEZED AMERICAN MEAT AND GAS
SUPPLY.
ARMS CONTROL AS THE U.S. AND
RUSSIA ARE THE WORLD'S BIGGEST
NUCLEAR POWERS.
AND ALEXI NAVALNY A PUTIN
POLITICAL RIVAL IN PRISON IN
RUSSIA.
>> NAVALNY'S DEATH WOULD BE
ANOTHER INDICATION THAT RUSSIA
HAS LITTLE OR NO INTENTION OF
ABIDING BY BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN RIGHTS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ALSO SEEMS TO
THINK PUTIN CAN BE A PARTNER
REINING IN OTHER BAD ACTORS.
>> REINING IN NUCLEAR THREATS
FROM IRAN AND NORTH KOREA.
>> HE MENTIONS IRAN EVEN THOUGH
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTS
MOSCOW IS OUTFITTING TEHRAN WITH
A SOPHISTICATED SPY SATELLITE.
>> I'M LESS CONCERNED HOW JOE
BIDEN STUMBLES AND BUMABLES HIS
WAY THROUGH DESCRIBING VLADIMIR
PUTIN THAN I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW JOE BIDEN BEHAVES TOWARDS
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> ON RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN
AMERICAN ELECTIONS, CANDIDATE
BIDEN CLAIMED TRUMP WASN'T TOUGH
ENOUGH ON PUTIN.
>> HE IS PUTIN'S PUPPY.
>> ONCE PRESIDENT, BIDEN TOOK IT
A STEP FURTHER.
>> YOU KNOW VLADIMIR PUTIN, DO
YOU THINK HE IS A KILLER?
>> UM-HUH, I DO.
>> THAT COMMENT HAD PUTIN
CALLING FOR A LIVE TELEVISED
CHAT WITH BIDEN WHO IS NOW
TRYING FLATTERY INSTEAD.
>> A WORTHY ADVERSARY.
>> AND TOMORROW COMBINES A QUEST
TO HAVE A BETTER WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH PUTIN THAT
BEGAN FOR BIDEN 10 YEARS AGO.
>> VERY GOOD NEWS IS THE
PRESIDENT AND I AGREE
100 PERCENT ON THE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ESTABLISH CLOSER AND
CLOSER RELATIONSHIP.
>> WEEKS AGO THERE WAS
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS MEETING WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
AT ALL.
AND A LOT OF WILL THEY OR WON'T
THEY.
ONCE IT WAS ANNOUNCED, THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS GOING TO
COME HERE BECAUSE THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT HE WANTED
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO HEAR.
AND NOW THAT IT'S THE EVE OF THE
MEETING, WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
LOWERING EXPECTATIONS A BIT
SAYING THEY DON'T EXPECT THERE
TO BE A BIG SET OF WHAT THEY
CALL "DLIRVELT" AND IT'S THE
FIRST ONE ON ONE SIT DOWN
BETWEEN PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE
LEADER OF A COUNTRY THAT HE ONCE
RECENTLY DESCRIBED NOT AS
COMPETITOR BUT AS AN OPPONENT.
SHANNON?
>> Shannon: ALL RIGHT, PETER
DOOCY ON THE ROA